a nasa spacecraft has briefly landed on
an
asteroid called bennu over 320 million
kilometers from
earth the acerous rex collected rock and
dust samples that scientists hope will
allow them to learn more about how
planets formed
and life began touchdown declared
two words that nasa scientists have
waited for
since 2016 when robotic spacecraft
osiris-rex
started its journey to the asteroid
bennu for the past
two years of its mission osiris-rex has
been orbiting the asteroid
looking for the perfect spot to land for
only a brief encounter
a few seconds almost like a kiss on the
surface
was all the time osiris-rex had to grab
rock and dust samples from the asteroid
seconds that have been years in the
making
i can tell you that everything went just
exactly perfect
which is kind of the hallmark of this
team we have consistently
beaten expectations over and over again
we have overcome the amazing challenges
that this asteroid has thrown at us
and the spacecraft appears to have
operated flawlessly
it was the first time nasa has touched
down on an asteroid
but it could be a week before scientists
know if and how much the spacecraft
grabbed
still the mission is already a success i
mean i can't believe we actually pulled
this off
if the sample collection was successful
osiris-rex will begin its long journey
home
and return to earth in 2023
for more let's bring in david brown he's
an astronomer at the university of
warwick thanks for being with us dr
brown
first of all tell us why is this mission
so important what do we hope to learn
good morning well this is a primordial
asteroid we think it hasn't changed very
much
since the the beginning of the solar
system since the start the sun and the
planets were all formed
so by studying it we hope to learn a
little bit more about those
early stages of the solar system and how
the earth
evolved and grew and formed and how the
different planets and different parts of
the solar system have interacted with
each other through time
okay um this mission we're talking about
a four-year journey
just getting there 300 million
kilometers away
and the mission is only halfway through
what's the trickiest part
of all this well thankfully the
hardest part the trickiest part was the
one that was completed last night was
the touch and grab
maneuver this had to be done completely
remotely because of the time delay
um in receiving signals from the earth
to the spacecraft
um and because of the surface of the
asteroid being a lot more
um bolder covered than they expected
when they first got there
and that the spacecraft had to maneuver
through some quite tight spaces
um but i think the hardest part has
successfully been completed now
it's hard to imagine communicating with
something over 300 million kilometers
away
is it clear that the spacecraft actually
collected what it was hoping to get from
that asteroid
not yet unfortunately and there were
some photographs taken by the spacecraft
during the touch and grab
but because the radio dish wasn't
pointing at the earth at the time we
haven't yet downloaded those images
and that should happen over the next
couple of days and that should tell us
give us some idea of whether it's been
successful there are also some other
tests that the spacecraft will perform
over the next week or so just to double
check and if it turns out that it wasn't
successful on this first attempt they do
have another chance and another
potential landing site to try again okay
so you should know soon whether you
actually got the dusts and
rock that it was set out to get when
will scientists actually be able to
start
analyzing the results of this mission
completely
so the images as i said should come
through
in the next few days there are other
images that will get over a slightly
longer time scale
so in terms of photograph analysis um
that announce that can start fairly soon
and actually analyzing the material we
get back should be a few years the
spacecraft is due to return in 2023
and that's really when we'll get our
hands on this this material and start
start digging into the mystery of this
asteroid
dr brown perhaps we'll get a chance to
talk again in 2023
david brown from the university of
warwick thank you very much
you